hello and welcome back to new rockstars
I'm Sam Bash and I'm here today to talk
about the most epic crossover in TV
history yes I'm claiming that's crisis
on Earth X we have characters from every
DC CW show you could possibly think of -
Smallville that won Aquaman teaser
anyways we were talking about the flash
Supergirl arrow and legends of tomorrow
whole in one mini movie not many though
cuz it's four hours longer than most
movies but hey I loved every second of
it I laughed I cried and my heart
swelled with hope but today I'm not here
to give you guys a review dang it I'm
here to point out every single Easter
egg pop culture reference all the other
goodies that were hidden throughout
every single one of these four episodes
here's your spoiler warning for the
four-part er the current and past
seasons of all the CW shows the comics
the movies etc etc you guys know it
let's kick it off let's start with comic
book connections DC TV show Gary here
has crazy will move through these
episodes from start to finish beginning
now starting with the opening with earth
x itself yes Earth X is an official
universe in the DC multiverse where the
heroic team of the Freedom Fighters
reside with the Ray and his team weirdly
though the CW decided to make earth X
the 53rd earth instead of the 10th
because you know X is the Roman numeral
for a 10 but hey you know didn't want
the Nazi University of like you know
official universe I get it also fun fact
depending on what comic you read the
reason Nazis won World War two on this
earth is either because of their nuclear
arsenal like in this crossover or
because Superman's pod landed in Germany
during World War two instead of Kansas
which led to him becoming the new Fuhrer
and taking over the entire world
it's Gary even has the same s symbol as
the evil doppelgangers and it's cross
over and you get a Nazi version of the
Justice League let's talk about the
freedom fighters for just a second the
do-gooders of Earth X like I said the
REA is usually a part of this team but
he is not the leader the leader is
actually Uncle Sam yes for real Uncle
Sam now based on the ads of the animated
series it doesn't look like we're gonna
get uncle me Uncle Sam in that series
but I think we got a nod to him in this
crossover look at the Guardians shield
in the opening scene normally the
Guardians just all gray but this one had
the Captain America treatment the stars
and stripes if you will sure it's not
Uncle Sam but it feels like a fun nod
next up we get Cara on her facing up
against a Dominator in National City
from those
who don't remember the dominators where
the alien race that tried to eradicate
all metahumans or meta abilities in last
year's four episode crossover they're a
race of aliens from the comics and I'm a
big fan of their design on the show got
to be honest I love this joke right here
so last year speaking of aliens we got
to shout outs to other alien races that
I hope pop up on one of these shows is
it sorry integra might is actually a
character from the Superman comics a bug
light creature that can leap great
distances and weave cocoons and such but
the other one is a very exciting nod I
mean that's the race of aliens that Lobo
is a part of Lobo being one of DC's most
famous anti-heroes I'm a big fan
currently on the JLA roster in the
comics but usually he's an alien bounty
hunter oh my goodness I need him on one
of these shows probably Supergirl next
we have a little nod to one of
Superman's obscure abilities listen to
this line here I know that you were
incapable of putting on weight which I
totally resent I was confused by this
line but I actually think this is a
throwback to one of Superman's super
eating abilities from MU a long time ago
comics way a long time ago they call
that the past you could just eat and eat
and eat me never attack on anyway kind
of like most superheroes for some
frickin reason then we get a fun nod
from some flash lore and a fun scene
from the Young Justice series with this
line you could always speed read it
no no one understand me yes the flash
can speed read and speed speak speed
talk speed speak is more fun to say
which only he and other speedsters can't
understand there are this clip between
Barry and impulse every fifth word may
be given back to earth X for just a
moment over girl was established in the
comics on earth X but she too is dead
check out this panel dang it she's a
Nazi though so now back on earth one
let's look at that serum for firestorm
which was meant to separate them and
then the other serum that Stein made
that supposed to give Jack spider powers
one awesome shout-out to spider-man it's
not the first mention we've had of the
webhead on these shows so I really
appreciated it and the spectacular
stickyman line happy into the two colors
of the serums felt like a nod to the
colors of fire storms flames and death
storms flames death storm being the
doppelganger from earth-2 who was in
season two of the flash look at his
comic book version he's scary looking
next up here's the big one that the
internet is exploding over the waitress
that stopped Barry at his wedding
there are many fan theories online as to
who this could be and I think most of
you guys are already on the right track
you can all pretty much agree that this
is most likely Don Allen Barry and
irises doctor one-half of the tornado
twin my guess is that she's not back in
time to watch her parents get married oh
that's sweet but there's another option
too that some people haven't brought up
Joe and Cecile are having a baby correct
yes it is because I watched the show as
well and then my other flash videos I've
mentioned that there could be a
possibility of that child
turning into some other version of Bart
Allen that way he's not Barry's grandson
but maybe he is his brother that he
raises that way you have a younger actor
on the show and that way he's not from
the distant future you know can work a
little bit better or maybe he's Daniel
West the reverse-flash from the new 52
but forget that for a second just for a
second my wild theories don't think
about it because what if Cecile and Joe
had a girl unfortunate circumstances
lead to Barry and iris raising her to
get speed powers of course cuz who
doesn't at Central City and runs back in
time to watch her parents wedding think
about it's not totally crazy hmm well
let's get to the big fight scene in the
church because there are a lot of
goodies here I'm gonna mention a bunch
of them later but the big one I want to
talk about right now is the awesome tie
to Marvel Comics let's take a look at
that move the car pulls out to get over
go off of her back she did the whole
clap
Superman's done this too before in the
comics but I feel it's more appropriate
to give Hulk the clap because Superman
takes too many people's powers in the
comics you guys don't know hope usually
slammed his hands together to create
high pressure waves that can you know
push back his foes definis enemies or
even put out fires which is pretty cool
even a clip of it from the last solo
Hulk movie let's take a look I like that
movie I don't really get the hate next
up we have a little nod to another
popular DC villain listen to what iris
calls Felicity here how long do you
brainiacs find these Nazis sure this is
actually a common term from the 50s I
guess but hey Brainiac on these shows
would be amazing you guys know he's the
main villain and injustice to the video
game oh boy he's scary I'd love to see
him on Supergirl writers you listening
these do that I'll play him next up is a
quick one so don't blink because there's
a cool nod to another DC team the Doom
Patrol what is the name of the optic
system building here this can't be an
accident Dayton is the last name of
Steve Dayton a cane
who's a member of the doom control team
controls a very wacky team of heroes and
I think we'd probably see them first if
we were to see them on a TV show on the
Titans DC show that they're developing
since a beast boy was originally a part
of the Doom Patrol hey they're
definitely weird enough to fit onto
these shows so next we get an epic
throwback to one of the biggest comics
ever The Dark Knight Returns thank you
guys know what I'm talking about that
kryptonite era that Oliver just whips
out just like what the future one-armed
a grizzled Green Arrow uses to peg
Superman when they're you know Batman's
fighting them he wants to fight them
it's a really good scene there's a
question though where did earth when
Oliver get Kryptonite how does he even
know what it is not a clue they didn't
answer it Shh not think about it can't
not think about it I don't know where he
got it then we see the return of one of
supergirls from now deceased foes from
season 2 metallo
no human parts anymore but is still cool
in fun fact the one time that he speaks
he's voiced by Fredrick Schmidt the
actor who played him before on Supergirl
metallo is usually a metahuman robot
hybrid that survives off a piece of
kryptonite in his chest to keep him
alive beacon of Superman throwbacks the
entire plot of over girl getting
saturated by solar radiation and dying
because of it is from a famous Superman
story all-star Superman one of my
favorites in this story Lex Luthor trick
Superman into getting exposed to too
much solar radiation and it ends up
killing him so Thursday our comic next
up let's talk about the array finally
the original array was Lanford tyrell
but now raid tyrell is currently on the
JLA team in the comics his main powers
are light absorption and flight shooting
light rays all over the place he even
can manipulate lights sometimes and
create constructs just like the Green
Lantern's can can't wait to see his solo
series on the CW scene she'd be fun him
being from Earth one is you know kind of
weird honestly but this could be a nod
to when the Ray was actually on earth
one in the main DC Universe but what's
not fun is Supergirl getting exposed to
red sunlight in the comics red sunlight
saps Kryptonians of their abilities and
makes them vulnerable fun fact other
forms have sunlight can have different
effects on Kryptonians like blue
sunlight can supercharge them and help
we see that on the Supergirl TV show the
next hero we meet is the one and only
citizen called the Captain Cold of Earth
X to fun things we finally got the
classic captain called glasses with the
little slits to the foe glasses which is
awesome and more comic accurate and his
design on his suit feels more like the
comic book version of Captain Cold and
to citizen cold who's the
character in this episode is actually
from the flashpoint storyline in the
comic and he's still pretty much villain
he's not a hero like he is here he's a
very corrupt hero lovely Oh though
beginner villains we get a fun nod to
the reverse-flash fighting Superman
which is amazing punted bit I thought
your cousin was in the future he is fast
I'm faster does this mean that Superman
comes to earth one does that mean that
he was on this earth but after what faun
did killing Barry's mom he never landed
here or does that mean that Superman
will eventually join the rest of the CW
characters Oh too many questions who
knows that's the answer nobody knows
Superman has met reverse-flash in the
comics and I've read some comics where
he and zoom not reverse-flash have
fought and Superman had doesn't doesn't
he doesn't win I'll be honest but it
would be awesome to see that live action
then we get the return of a villain from
Supergirl now he's kind of a hero slash
villain / weapon Red Tornado
we got Red Tornado back in season 1 of
Supergirl and I was not a fan of how
they brought him to the small screen
check it out right there he looks pretty
rough but this one is pretty freakin
Doug won't be honest the CG kind of just
works for him Red Tornado in the show
and comics is an Android who can create
manipulate gale force winds that allows
him to fly and fight with them he's a
badass and I kind of wish he would come
back maybe to one of these shows as a
recurring character please moving
forward we get Rey aka the atom saving
Supergirl in an awesome moment we also
get a fun nod to an elastic heroes right
here in beginning usually the atom
shrinks and grows this whole body not
just you know parts of it but our
elastic heroes are known for doing that
all the time like an elongated man
Plastic Man miss Marvel and mr.
fantastic I'm gonna be honest it felt
like they were teasing the atom going
giant and fighting someone somehow in
this crossover but it's like what I can
get maybe next year now moving on to the
moment that made me cry like a baby the
death of Martin Stein now this has
happened kind of in the comics before
sometimes he does usually come back like
most comic book characters even came
back one time as the elemental firestorm
he kind of lived in the firestorm matrix
which is confusing I don't think that's
happening in this show unfortunately but
as for a replacement form I know that
there have been other people who've
taken up the mantle but who would you
guys want it to be would you like it to
be a new
character or character that's already on
legends of tomorrow let me know in the
comments down below next we get to
awesome Superman / Supergirl moments one
harry's saying this iconic line need to
fly up up and away it was one of the
cheesiest deliveries ever and I loved it
too Man of Steel on earth 1 catching the
Girl of Steel seems reminiscent of the
crisis on Infinite Earths classic shot
of Superman holding Supergirl you know
had that before in other shows but this
is still cool also he may have just lost
his arms I don't understand how he
caught her but enough with the comic
book ties let's start talking about
connections to other DC shows and movies
like when Jimmy Olsen showed up in the
beginning on Earth X of course everyone
knows he's from Supergirl and he didn't
really show up in any other way during
this crossover which was a bummer but
hey it was great seeing him also I love
the crisis on earth X logo which is like
a recreation of the new Marvel Studios
logo showing all their characters all
you know doing their thing then we get
the return of Kingdom shark the
metahuman from Earth to wreaking havoc
in Central City last time we saw him it
was an Argus with Grodd must have been a
big breakout cuz grog got out too I also
liked how they wrote the city's names
with the font that they used further
shows is pretty cool and the theme of
crisis on earth Dex is a mash-up of all
the themes of the other shows thanks we
get a fun crossover with DC and Legion
on FX because this random Nazi
scientists here played the villainous I
last season on Legion don't think you'll
be coming back but I knew I recognized
them from something then scooting
forward to firestorm playing their split
up their breakup if you will here
mention of a quark sphere the same
sphere they used to trick the Speed
Force and to get Barry back I don't know
what it means but it's fun scientific
gobbledygook we also got a nod to the
first firestorm Ronnie r.i.p when they
talk about Ronnie and Caitlin's wedding
during the flash season 1 finale and a
fun throwback to the musical crossover
from last season between flash and
Supergirl when cara sang running home to
you I'll be honest I teared up a little
bit here don't judge me then we got a
huge twist with the return of Tommy
Merlyn as prometheus from Earth X Y Z
dressed like Prometheus it doesn't make
any sense doesn't matter because we have
Tommy back alright guys also in the
comics Tommy is a version of Merlin or
the dark Archer so this works then we
get a fund onto the MCU when the Nazi
doppelgangers take off their masks in
this style of one star-lord of how the
mask just kind of crawls over their face
why do they why they wearing masks to be
honest Shh
it was a fun surprise but I will point
out something weird why is the
reverse-flash on earth X why is it a
dead version of the reverse-flash
how was he back from the dead I
literally I don't have any idea he's
died like three times now and I can't I
can't keep track of it anymore which
version of this it is like I don't know
but let me know your theories down below
also why they let him go capture and put
him in jail do something anything
anything when talking about this
showdown in the parking lot I did notice
a few things this kind of felt like the
showdown in the Justice League Unlimited
cartoon and the team fought the Brainiac
versions of themselves remember that
also I notice when the skyscrapers
started falling apart it felt like the
skyscraper that kind of got collapsed in
the age of Ultron movie between you know
the Hulk and Iron Man fight also it felt
like spider-man homecoming a little bit
when pier was trying to hold together
with his webs don't know where Oliver
got those web arrows from but hey it
worked for what was happening I should
just tear down that building though it's
not even finished yet just rebuild
rebuild a little bit we also got a fun
throwback to Wells in season 1 in his
fake wheelchair it's a real wheelchair
but he's just a dirty dirty liar mouth
also fans of Young Justice did you feel
like those inhibitor collars that they
were wearing on Earth X felt like the
collars from Young Justice
they stopped meta abilities on that show
and usually on these shows we just see
cuffs so it was kind of fun to see the
collars that's cool
and with this Justice League esque
crossover we got a small nod to the
large screen Justice League with Sara's
line here good might be an
oversimplification oversimplification
that feels like an oversimplification
nice one CW you guys nailed the Justice
League event without even saying the
name Justice League also it was good
seeing win show up as the general on
earth X but why can't him and Cisco mean
they're basically the same person they'd
have a great time together just rude now
own a few things I wanted to mention
really quick it's kind of interesting
that Oliver is a mayor / leader of Star
City on earth one on earth X he's like a
mayor as well but of the world in a
violent dictatorship he's a Fuhrer born
later any university go to also
something kind of fun deep well in
writer you know the name of the Nazi
Waverider just translates to Waverider
in German the more you know next we
actually got another nod to the Justice
League and Smallville weirdly enough
shout out we have a o bar talking about
the Age of Heroes which feels just like
Diana's line in the Justice League or at
least in the trailer and that entire
disk from eobard about how Felicity will
never be remembered felt just like when
the Legion
superheroes we're trying to figure out
if they wanted to kill Chloe Sullivan
when she was taken over by Brainiac
buddy else remember that I watched all
its Millville I don't know if you guys
did also I doubt that you guys caught
this one because this was an awesome
Easter Egg remember the evil Gideon on
the Nazi Waverider she kind of sound
familiar
or at least different without a
transplant she'll be dead within an hour
well this is actually the voice of
Suzanna Thompson aka Moira queen from
Season one and two of arrow
Oliver's mommy then we get a fun nod to
Captain America Civil War in Marvel
Comics when you saw Adam riding one of
those tea spheres from mister terrific
much like ant-man riding enough
Hawkeye's arrows not sure what he's
gripping on to it's a big ball but still
cool it's actually pretty cool to hear
caro say this line you can order stuff
outside this is a nod to the Donner
Superman movies listen here know would
you care to step outside and finally
nearing the end of the crossover we got
a tease of the CW heroes helping out Rey
on Earth X with this line look if you
ever need us to do any punching over on
earth X just let us know well do and of
course the poster for the freedom
fighters web series you can see Cisco
breaching on to their earth also you
can't have a crossover without Diggle
vomiting because of Barry's SuperSpeed
am i right and lastly guys here a quick
few pop-culture references from other
movies or TV shows or just historical
references that you guys may have missed
like the Lightning SS symbol on the evil
doppelgangers is actually the original
SS symbol or the paramilitary Nazi
organization then scooting forward to
1183 ad when the legends are accused of
being Robin Hood now they haven't met
Robin Hood yet on the show eventually
they will of course they will but also
we get plenty of Robin Hood jokes during
the first couple seasons of arrow
because just make sense and when the
boys are trying on their tuxes you can
hear Barry saying this beyonce lyric you
love her I love her so much
put a ring on her real worked a little
bit but it's still you know it works
then we gonna shout out to Sponge Bob
Squarepants and neighbor Squidward right
here what Squidward here needs to say is
cuz Harry Wells is basically a real-life
Squidward chemicals and all probably
it's earth to I don't know what they're
like then we get a small reminder of
this Thor line from work with singing
his husband boyfriend maybe just friend
ask him Mick if he's a friend from work
friend from work and we get actually the
most important crossover of all time
because the greatest American hero actor
William Katt is the minister to Barry
and irises wedding you guys don't know
that show it's a guy who gets
superpowers but he's a big old dingus I
mean if Diggle couldn't do it I'd trust
will to get the job done am i right
later we hear this line from Prometheus
which is funny because the opposite
happens well it's not funny it's sad
because you still have a funeral but you
got two weddings also just want to point
this out the background of the breach
room definitely looks like a flux
capacitor so you're welcome for that
distracting little tidbit I get these
shows time travel a lot so it's cool I
guess one little fun joke blink and
you'll miss it when Mick is asking for
mustard for a sandwich he's brought
German mustard ha ha cuz Nazis from
Germany let me get the fun all over in
the high castle joke miss Oliver the
high castle which is a nod to man in the
high castle a show about an alternate
world where Nazis took over the United
States also Stalag STAR Labs is a nod to
the stolid camps or POWs camps in World
War two Germany then we skipped episode
3 where we actually learned some pretty
depressing history about World War 2
slogan above the camp that the heroes
are in is an actual slogan that was used
at the entrance of concentration camps
it translates to work sets you free also
the triangles and stars that were put on
people's clothing are real as well like
the REA having a pink triangle which was
actually used to identify homosexuals
and the Star of David on alternate
Felicity used to identify people of the
Jewish faith also Quentin's alternate
name is sturmbannfuhrer probably
mispronounced that try my best guys is
actually the name of leaders in the
German army in world war ii there's more
german references as well but let's try
to focus on the fun of the cross so we
had characters referring to eobard as
Mengele who is the infamous Nazi
scientist experimented on prisoners and
concentration camps sorry that's not so
much fun but this is fun we had iris and
felicity referring to each other as
McLain as in John McClane the main
character of the die hard films who
snuck around inside of
air ducts also just wanted to point out
that stormtroopers and Star Wars get
their name from the Nazi storm troopers
and just like in Star Wars these
stormtroopers have horrible aim like
look at this
not a single head and there's like 30
people just firing machine guns wildly
everywhere also just listen to this clip
cause I don't want a butcher at the
German gateway is guarded by 30 pounds
or 1250 Sturm Tigers and 100 should stop
all officers those right there are two
types of tanks and the full name of the
SS which I was bummed about because a
sturm tiger sounds like a super villain
I'm a nerd I also get some fun
Terminator references with this one
pretty on the nose but also this one you
want to live fun since you know there's
an actual Terminator walking around
really cool when he blew up I also get a
fun nod I feel like to the Hellboy movie
when the Nazis get sucked into the
breach and they just explode gross cool
also we get some Top Gun references with
this Kosinski wine walk in the park
Kozinski short but fun and a fun
shout-out to star raters the Atari game
hooray
everyone's favorite it's just like Star
readers in Atari except it's real
actually hooray one more time because we
made it that's it real quick though some
stray observations those people are bad
friends for RSVP'ing for a wedding days
before it happened how are their 53 cars
and the multiverse there isn't one on
earth one unless she's dead and that's
depressing
also I missed the Hall of Justice from
last year's crossover where is it can we
go back there have a vacation there whoo
anyways guys thank you so much for
watching let me know if any of these
facts were your favorite or if I missed
anything that you thought was really
important hit me up in the comment
section also like this video subscribe
the new rock stars and check out all of
our other breakdowns I'm Sam basher you
can check me out on twitter at sam
basher and i'll see you guys next time